[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum how are you today ryan
good to see you
good to see you as well you just fixed
your hair because it was a little messy
a minute ago i'm gonna say something
my hair is so long i don't know what to
do with it anymore uh have you ever
heard of a haircut
uh no can you tell me about it well i
haven't had one in a little while but uh
that doesn't help well you can get a
haircut can't you you fear
going in there you're not vaccinated no
i'm not
yeah so your hair is standing straight
up
is it is it bad what are you gonna do i
guess if you're listening you're gonna
have to tune in on youtube
uh you know my friend sent me this quote
we were talking about uh
you know he gets a lot of anxiety and
stuff i play ice hockey and he's an old
hockey buddy joey and he says
we're talking about anxiety and life and
he says you know
you know marcus aurelius i'm like want
to know him but
uh he had a quote he says we are more
frightened than hurt
and we suffer more in imagination than
reality
i thought that was pretty interesting
because it's our minds that f
with us the most right we're always
thinking about
disaster doom and gloom
and our minds are much more i don't know
i
i think that's so accurate it's like if
i could just get out of my own head out
of my own way
do you do that are you in your own way
of course how do we just get out how do
we just say hey man life is good let's
just like you know whatever hits us
there's some people that either
they're [ __ ] liars that just go yeah
i just go with the flow
and they're happy and they don't think
too much i think when you think too much
you're just you're you're done the
minute you start thinking over
thinking uh that's when things get
complicated for me
i agree i was also trying to i was also
dry swallowing
were you dry swallowing i've never heard
of the word the term dry
swallowing i don't think i ever want to
hear that again i never want to hear the
terms dry swelling
i hope you guys had a fantastic weekend
if you're here for matthew lewis
a friend of mine um neville longbottom
from harry potter's and tons of tons of
other [ __ ] too
and um if you're here for him i urge you
to give this show a chance
and uh subscribe on youtube and apple
spotify whatever
tune in you might just learn something
every week i know i learn things ryan
learns things the guest learns things
and i think
uh all of you might matthew lewis is a
good buddy he uh we met at a convention
signing autographs
and uh he was really sweet and he was
with his uh
one of his buddies years ago and um they
ended up crashing at my house when they
came to l.a
him and his buddy nick and we became
friends
and then i my brother and i went out to
england
made a pit stop and he picked us up from
the airport took us to leeds and on the
way he we stopped by the harry potter
sets and saw the owls and all the little
i mean the og man it was there and it
was uh
and i've never been a huge harry potter
fan i've never like i've never seen all
the movies uh
obviously now with him and as a friend i
was like you know i have to check him
out but
um you know it was uh it was interesting
he's such
a laid-back down-to-earth guy loves his
leads he's a big leads fan he just goes
on about that and
i love that but you're gonna get a kick
out of this interview it's a lot of fun
also uh please follow us uh we would
really appreciate the support
follow us ryan tell them where the hand
what the handles are uh inside of you
pawed on twitter
inside of you podcast on instagram and
facebook that is correct please
subscribe on youtube
please subscribe to apple podcast please
write a review it helps
substantially if you're enjoying this
show at all uh it really does help uh
it's like those little mon paw
stores that you want to help out it's uh
the same thing or that little podcast
that could
and we will podcast a mon podcast
mon podcast that's a great name for a
podcast
the mon podcast i hope that hasn't been
done yet
but just like just a mod posture
someone's stealing that right now
whoever's listening you're welcome
you're [ __ ] welcome i also urge you
big uh
big shows coming up for uh the band sun
spin here's the
album you can get at sunspin.com you can
get the vinyl
or without the vinyl the vinyl will be
out soon but you can get the cd and uh
beanies and shirts and lunch boxes and
autographs
on the sunspin.com site and we're
playing sunspin we're going to play the
entire album maybe a cover to
march 27th which is just in a few days
uh 2 p.m and a 6 p.m show pacific
standard time so we hope you'll join us
go to stageit.com
and just type in sun spin and uh join us
that's going to be a lot of fun
and if you want any cool inside of you
merch we got tons of new stuff we got
new tumblers and and the new white mugs
came in
and shirts and smallville stuff
autographed
smallvo lunchbox and shirts and stuff
you can go to the inside of you online
store to get all that stuff i usually
have discounts and things like that but
uh
in fact why don't we throw a discount at
them give me a give me a name and a
number how about a
want to say uh 15 off everything i was
going to say jenny 8675309
but that's not what you're looking for
that's a little long okay
how about i don't know inside ryan
oh no inside r-y-a-n it's inside
ryan and i said 15 so we got to go 15
right all right
inside ryan 15 and that will give you 15
off everything in the store and that's
only going to be for a couple days so
you might want to rack that up will you
remind me ryan
inside ryan 15. that's correct that is
the code today
okay so i'm going to say i appreciate
everybody out there listening
continually
continuing to listen to the podcast and
everything ryan by the way is uh is
everything going okay in your life
i mean it's you look a little uh a
little bit uh
frantic inside like i can see there's
like some things going on
is everything go going all right yeah i
mean it's as okay as it can be i mean i
just
i've worked too much and i'm looking
forward to not working as much and i
don't know how to do that
yeah you know that's the thing we either
work too much or we don't work at all
and then we have too much time on our
hands or we don't have any time on our
hands and
we got to give ourselves a break i mean
uh i'm i'm trying
i i'm still going through the whole you
know adjusting to some meds and things
like that and just trying to
you know lower the anxiety and then
sometimes you you take a little too much
and then you're more
anxious and it's just that you know
sometimes i'm just like [ __ ] it man i'm
just gonna get off all of it again and
just
uh go back to the beginning and i think
back the old days and i wasn't uh
anxiety ridden i mean there was always
an anxiousness to me
and i didn't realize that it was
people say well use that to your benefit
man the anxiety the
and uh i just didn't like living like
that or living like that
i think that's the that's the thing but
uh you know i'm doing my best and i'm
being a little more active this week
which helped
i got an epidural in my back they uh
they gave me some injections in my spine
and that helped me
because i had some lower really major
lower back problems i've had some you
know
back problems my whole life and i'm just
trying to this is a fixing stage this
whole pandemic has been a time where
i'm learning too much about myself but
i'm also
taking care of things while while we're
still here
because the lights at the end of the
tunnel we see the light it's coming
the vaccines are coming but i'm trying
to get
to a place where i feel just really
really good isn't it crazy though this
last week was the year
was like the anniversary of the official
los angeles lockdown
this week like yeah last week jesus that
was intense man
that's i've been thinking about that a
lot yeah i i posted a
st patrick's day song on twitter i was
like oh this will just be a silly month
and i was just looking at that person
from a year ago and i don't know i do
not feel the same i
don't feel the same as that person it's
weird it is weird and it's uh i hope
that it's giving a
give everyone out there a different
perspective on just life
and like camaraderie on like for sure
just being more of a human being and
listening to people and
being more present and you know maybe
this is a wake-up call i hope people see
it like that i know a lot of people
probably won't and um
you know get worse but i'm trying to be
a little optimistic i hope
we all start listening to each other and
loving each other just a little bit more
because uh boy i mean a lot of people
died
and a lot of [ __ ] went down in this last
year and you just hope that this is a
year that people remember
and and learn from i don't know
i want to be optimistic but uh anyway
here's to everyone getting vaccinations
if that's what you believe in
um you could shoot me in my butthole for
all i care i want to be just done with
this
and i want to go travel and i want to do
my thing so get me vaccinated get the
world
back to work and uh let's get inside
of matthew lewis it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael
[Music]
rosenbaum
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
matt lewis by the way do you like i mean
do you like matthew
do you like matt do you like matthew
which one
my mom calls me matthew um but most of
my friends call me matt so that's all
right what is your wife calling you
besides [ __ ] clean the office mostly
that but matt i think she calls me
mostly
sports people call me matty have you
ever noticed that spo i don't know if
it's the same in the us but in the uk
all sports people have to put like a it
has to be like
a y sound on the end of it rosie i'm
rosie rosie
yeah yeah i'm mighty and i'd i've never
ever told anyone to call me matty i hate
it but all sports people
without ever asking me call me that now
you have a podcast as well every [ __ ]
actor now has a podcast
pandemic podcast in it this was kind of
a dream to you because you're you're
from yorkshire
is it yorkshire yorkshire yorkshire
yorkshire
so leeds is obviously your your favorite
team leeds united
okay yeah well first of all my buddy
right here my engineer you can't see him
ryan
his family right is from leeds oh
they're from harrogate uh
and like oh wow no [ __ ] my uncles are
huge uh lead supporters
that's funny yeah howard it's beautiful
have you been oh uh several times yeah
yeah
we always feel like i've been flying
into leeds bradford my whole life
i didn't fly bradford matt he he picked
me up at uh
london heathrow and we drove to leeds do
you remember that yeah man
that was a good time we were listening
we should have gone to harrogate we
could have gone to the turkish bass in
harrogate that would've been nice
wait what a turkish bath mm-hmm
it's it's a bath yeah it's like a it's
like a spa like uh so you do all the
steam rooms and all that and they've got
the frigidaire which is like you know
the ice baths and stuff it's good it's
nice are people in there with you
yeah there's got you can do you can do
full naked days i think with
the men and women together uh not the
naked ones i think they're
uh i think they're not co-ed them
hey so look i know you moved to florida
which broke my heart because every one
of my friends moves away and i'm
starting to get a complex here
but i mean you moved to florida
and it was your fault it was but you
know i you told me
why you said look it's the middle ground
it's uh you know you're not too far from
your family in london or in leeds
and angela's there with her family and
you could always fly out to la
which you don't come out to l.a much do
you unless you have a big audition or
something
well we we actually had planned to like
because because ange made like when we
were there
angie made some really really great
friends like really close friends and
they've been over
around europe together and we had
planned in 2020 to come back to l.a for
quite a bit
um obviously that got [ __ ] on by um the
pandemic
um but yeah absolutely i mean florida
was
was was going to be a base for us but we
actually
we planned on kind of flitting around a
little bit like i wouldn't spend a bit
of time in new york we're going to go
and um
spend like three months up in new york
and then we're going to come back out to
l.a for a bit but we just uh
yeah just uh that's all following
through along with everyone else around
the world's plans as well like
world's tiniest violin um but yeah like
we will once once everyone's back once
everyone's back to it we'll uh we'll
certainly uh
we'll be heading out there again yeah
you know all this the whole covet thing
i mean a lot of people have been dealing
everybody's dealing with it in their own
way and everybody has hard times and
everybody
you know obviously my anxiety's been
through the roof uh
you know i've been you know in therapy
and trying to deal with my [ __ ]
and uh you know you have good times you
have bad times but i think i got a
little
what's called cabin fever remember in
the shining yeah when
he's telling jack nicholson he's like
well a man um
delbert grady he was a caretaker good
man no no uh
previous records of anything violent or
anything but he brought his family up
here for the winner and uh
after a couple of months he got what
some people call
cabin fever you know just kind of lost
his mind and he
chopped his daughters up with an axe and
shot his wife with a shotgun
and uh anyway so it's not that i'm just
saying that i remember
that way you're right is it no no no i'm
not like that i don't get violent i just
i just sometimes wake up or i don't
really i don't sleep well i get anxious
have you gotten i know you're a pretty
mellow guy but do you
do you get anxiety um i tell you one
thing
i do i do and i don't i mean like i
i definitely feel um
at times sort of anxious and overwhelmed
and stuff like that but
it it's it's not it's not debilitating
in the way that i know the actual
medical definition of it is so i would
never
i would never say i have anxiety i think
it can be quite
i know it's i know it's a you know it's
a
it's a heavily used term but when i've
seen people who genuinely suffer from
anxiety
and it can be really debilitating and
they can't like they don't want to get
out of bed or they don't want to leave
the house or whatever and they can't
like i mean my wife gets it sometimes
and she can't even speak you know
and it's like i would never want to
reduce that by saying oh yeah i get
anxiety
like i get anxious about things but i
don't have anxiety if that makes sense
yeah
um um but i yeah absolutely i mean i get
i get certainly get
get quite overwhelmed with with the job
at times usually when i'm when i'm in
the middle of a job
and i'm panicking about it being [ __ ]
okay so oh wait so do you equate
success with happiness like
if you are great or like you're
you're insatiable obviously you want to
be great we all want to be great
we want the studios to think we're great
and but
uh after a while you know the older i
get to rely
i realize i just got to do the best i
can and by the way i'm not saying
i'm i'm good with this now but like
you know when is it good enough or what
what is it that makes you anxious about
that
well i think the there's there's a
couple of things so like my
my because i i was seeing a
therapist for a little while um and
it was simply because um
and again like it wasn't anything
debilitating i just thought i think that
there's not
there shouldn't be a stigma around it
for a start and i thought
well i'm not working it's i'm a bit down
in the dumps i'm sort of like
um i didn't feel um
fulfilled inspired i didn't feel
inspired to do anything i felt like
i just couldn't be bothered and even
when and it wasn't if like i was out
like self tapes were coming in i just
couldn't be bothered and i was like
what's wrong with with this
so i spoke to someone and it was fine
like it was it was all right and
uh we came out the other end of it and
actually moving back to florida helped a
great deal
um but but she said something quite
interesting to me she said that you need
to find
something in your life that that you can
do
so that you can remove your job from
from being the sole thing that defines
you
because it was like everything that i
was doing
every choice that i was making in life
um had all been to try and make
myself as successful as possible and
therefore every time that i was a
setback where i didn't get a role or
um or something wasn't as successful as
it could have been or a bad review
it was like that was all-consuming
that suddenly that was a reflection on
me as a human being not just to me as an
actor but also me as
me as my worth as a person um
and i mean she told me that i haven't
fixed that i haven't done what she's
told me to do
yeah well [ __ ] it's you know what it is
you're acknowledging it because
you see truth behind it and that's
that's exactly you can't
we can't value ourselves or our
self-worth
based on you know what we do all we
could base it on is
how uh you know our work ethic how hard
we try
being a decent person there's things you
can control and then there's a lot of
things you can't
well i think you just summed it up in
that you just said there that you're
trying your best i think the the the
crucial
thing is if something [ __ ] is [ __ ] okay
maybe you were just wrong for
the role or you just didn't get it right
or whatever like but as long as you can
come away from that and you go you know
what i did the very best that i could
like i i i did i worked hard i knew my
lines at the back of my hand i did all
the preparation i did
everything and and it worked
for me if it didn't resonate with with
that with that
uh critic or with those people then
i'm kind of i'm i'm learning to get
better at that because as long as the
only time i get really upset is when i
look back and i go you know what you
didn't
you didn't do everything you could have
done there right and i'm and i'm
i'm getting better to a point where i'm
like so long as i've done what i've all
i can do
you have to accept that and i said this
earlier like it's quite pretentious
thing to say but what we do is
is art and art by definition is is
subjective
and so like everything you do
is it's it's not going to resonate with
everyone it's not going to speak to
everyone um but as long as it spoke to
you and you believed it and you did
everything you could then it'll
it'll it'll say something to someone um
and uh that's the best you can do by the
way
in this day and age and i've talked
about this if you suck
the worst thing that's gonna happen is
you're on on twitter for five
seconds until the next thing happens and
everyone's forgotten that matthew lewis
once
sucked or was a subpar and i think that
maybe maybe i'm wrong
but was there that part of you because i
know there was that part of me for a
while where i played lex luthor and i
wanted like people to go i'm not i'm not
just lex luthor i'm not just a villain i
can do comedy
look at me i'm a monkey i could do
anything
do you think there's a part of like you
know i was never long but i'm that was a
character i'm different now i'm i'm
and you know obviously you're handsome
as [ __ ] you look completely different
you wore a fat suit you changed
they added teeth on you as neville but
do you ever as a part of you that just
wants to go
i want people to see how great i can
[ __ ] be and i'm not just
this character who was great i think
absolutely
like up until relatively recently that
would have absolutely have been a thing
and i still i still to a degree get a
bit frustrated sometimes when people
sort of say oh he's
he like for example i mean i'm doing
this show at the minute it's on pbs um
and like a lot of the headlines have
been oh he's no longer
never long bottom anymore and it's like
i haven't been that for 10 years and i
have done things that have been so
wildly different like
i've been in dramas that have won baftas
and i've done all this kind of stuff and
i'm not bragging it's just like i've
done all this stuff
and and yet still 10 years later it's
people
are making the claim that i've sort of
jumped from harry potter into this and
they've completely
ignored the the journey that it's taken
to get there
and and that's that i guess can be
frustrating um
because it feels like not that i'm
frustrated by anything to do with harry
potter but it feels like
you have that little voice in your head
that goes hey you know all that hard
work you did for the last 10 years
no one [ __ ] saw it no one cares all
right they're still like
it's like they still think this is the
first job you've done since harry potter
remember that performance no one watched
it
right and it's like that's not true
right but it's like that little thing
creeps in
but on the flip side of it i have been
doing a very good job lately and i don't
know if it comes from maturity
or age you know whatever i've done a
very good job of that i've
i've got to a point where i'm i'm
relatively comfortable in life
i'm happily married and
i'm pretty content with you know current
situation of pandemic aside i'm pretty
content with my lot and it's like
i have been in great films and great
shows and i've been very privileged and
fortunate for that
i kind of just want to work for myself
now good and it's like
if i do a role and and and someone
doesn't like it or didn't like didn't
think that it worked because they could
only see me as harry p
has never long bottom or all this thing
i'm like i don't give a [ __ ] because
when i was filming that for three months
i had the best three months of my life
and i got paid and i don't care well
listen to this i will tell you this
and thank you for sharing that with me
but i will say
that it's a blessing
that and i know you know this already
you've said this it's a blessing harry
potter was a blessing it was like you
know we've talked
about that ad nauseum but what they do
and what i do on the podcast um for
those that don't like if i said matt
lewis is on the podcast
a lot of people might say i don't know
who matt lewis is if i said michael
rosenbaum's on the pot well on my own
on your podcast they'd say who the [ __ ]
is michael rosenbaum so
i don't care anymore smallville's lex
luthor michael rosenbaum in the pockets
oh i love that show maybe i'll watch
that interview
harry potter's matthew lewis people go
oh i want to listen to what he has to
say i loved his character oh my god look
he's handsome
now they could see you as an adult as a
man as a good looking guy who's doing
all these things
and so sometimes i've accepted this and
it took me a while
but that what they do is they're trying
to promote
their show their whatever the best they
can so people will come and watch it and
then see how great you are
so it might seem a little bit like oh no
neville longbottom see how he's grown up
i mean they're gonna do that for the
history of your life probably i mean
harry
here's why harry potter was the biggest
sensation
in the history of cinema so
right you will never do anything that
great i mean you
you might but it's it's very well i
probably won't do anything as great as
small but it's just but it's true
and and and i'm and i'm you know i'm
it's it's it sounds ridiculous to say
but i am genuinely fine with that
like i'm genuinely just like you know if
i if i don't work again that would be
rubbish because i enjoy it
right and i've got nothing really else
to do i'm i sit and play playstation all
day
um so like i would like to keep working
but if those things are not
like blockbuster movies or
you know winning golden globes like i as
long as i enjoyed doing it
like that's that's if you if people are
going to pay me to do things that i
enjoy
and i'm not starving then i'm going to
be all right you know
well look at this i mean you've worked
with great people and when i look up
stuff on you like uh for instance all
creatures great and small
was really regarded high ratings
critical acclaim
new york times praised you you got to
believe the new york times unless you're
no i say i died man i i'll always come
up with some kind of
what could you come up with this guy
doesn't know you matthew lewis was
sensational as this character he really
uh conveyed such a lovely [ __ ]
well i mean what would you how do you
not believe a guy who's randomly writing
about you doesn't know you
i genuinely i just i i don't know i just
think that he's maybe
uh i don't know i always i just i i will
always come up with some
it's what i don't know whether we caught
this earlier i was talking to you about
it
but i was saying about how with our
industry the the outcome is
is is is so again subjective but it's
like there's no
ah there's no definitive end to it to it
like
we are saying that if if you're a
footballer and you win a game
you get to go home that night and you
are you are happy with your performance
because you got the win
if you uh are a banker and you made
loads of money for you
for your clients you've got the you've
done the job description
is to make money for your clients now
acting is like yeah okay we got the film
in the can we made the tv series
whatever
but like whether people enjoy it whether
it's actually any good is just
is so in the air it's not
you know and so it's just like i will
always find an excuse why
why it it wasn't good okay
until you are on a hit series and you've
won awards and it's gone for five
seasons
and then you have to say okay then what
are you gonna say
oh well that's just that then yeah i
mean when is it gonna be in matthew
lewis's mind
or maddie when is it gonna where you're
where you're going
where your your football players call
you that
yeah yeah your football boys i don't
like it are you just from you don't like
when they call you it either
no i hate it i absolutely i don't know
where it's coming from they're just all
sportsmen call me i don't know why
oh sportsman all sportsmen
give me the name matty and they've never
got it from anyone i've never told them
to call me that it's like this weird
like
locker room instinct that they have to
put a y on the end of my name
and you can't change that you've ever
said hey can you not call me that
no i mean it's quite charming like when
a premier league footballer gives you a
nickname it's quite exciting
like i'm not gonna say yo don't call me
that i just internally don't like it
when do you think you'll ever be content
or do you think that the insatiable side
of you that
sort of like that gives you the drive
that gives you what you need
even though it's self-deprecating and
it's all these things it's something
that
it's the cyclical process that you
torture yourself with
that you think you're going to just
continue on in life like this
i mean i would like to be i part of me
thinks i would like to be one of those
people who just believes
everything including the [ __ ] but
that's the problem isn't it i mean like
if you
i suppose there could be a happy medium
to be found
um but it's the idea of that i guess
i've always been nervous that you know
in our industry everyone
not everyone but a lot of people like to
blow smoke up your ass and
and and lie to your face about how good
something is
and it's and it's like i've always been
one of those people that i'll never buy
into that i'll never believe that you
know i'll always be i'll always take
that with a pinch of salt
but then it goes to the extreme where
you get a good review and it's like that
guy's full of [ __ ] he doesn't know he's
talking about he doesn't
he's he's an idiot why should i listen
to his opinion um
and it's like i never want to go the
other way where i believe
where i i guess if i take if i i worry
that if i take a good review and i
believe it then i'll believe anything
and and everyone's you know harry potter
fans are the best fans in the world
they're so lovely and so kind
and they say the sweetest things and and
it's like
with any fan base you you you have to
always worry are they did
they did they genuinely like what you
did or they just love harry potter and
that's why they said it
and you can get caught up in i think
that it's very easy to get caught up in
in uh in in fans sort of bigging you up
and then you start to pick yourself up
and then it's just it gets a bit i don't
know
i i would rather i would rather be
critical of myself than
than full of my own [ __ ] [ __ ] exactly
inside of you is brought to you by geico
we've been here before ryan we've talked
about geico geico is something everyone
knows
and i'm just gonna get to it you want
convenience you don't want to have to
have auto policy from one company and
renter's policy from another and
homeowners from another
you don't want any of that crap if you
rent your home or you you uh pay a
mortgage or whatever you do
you want to pay one person that's geico
they have bundling policies
make it easy it's so easy with geico
it's a it's a one-stop shop isn't it
ryan
it is geico makes it easy to bundle your
homeowners or renters insurance along
with your auto policy and it's a good
thing
we're all busy we have so much going on
in our lives
just go to geico make it easy go to
geico.com
get a quote see how much you could save
it's geico easy
visit geico.com today that's geico.com
even a rosenbomb can do it inside of you
is brought to you by true underdog
podcast raised in a trailer park with no
clear path to success kicked out of high
school multiple times faced with
becoming a father in his teens
jason waller is the definition of a true
underdog
after hearing the words no or you can't
too many times
he unleashed the power within to start
three successful companies with his most
recent venture
power home solar skyrocketing on a path
to becoming a billion dollar enterprise
join us as waller a four-time
entrepreneur of the year winner
shares motivational tips and inspiring
stories and business building lessons
from the ground up he shares his life
experiences
and that of his high profile guests to
help others better themselves
as waller will tell you there's no
elevator to success
that climb only happens one step at a
time let every true underdog podcast be
that step that elevates you
scared money won't make money learn
about failure
learn about entrepreneurship learn about
never quitting or making excuses
it's real it's raw it's motivational
check out true underdog podcast at
trueunderdog.com or anywhere
you get your podcasts inside of you is
brought to you by nitsa guys i know it
can be very frustrating for you
especially when you're in a hurry
you're running late and you find
yourself at a railway crossing waiting
for a train
and if the signals are going and the
train's not even there yet you may feel
a little bit tempted to
try and sneak across the tracks well i'm
telling you don't
do it ever to the naked eye trains often
appear to be further away and moving
slower than they
are and they can't stop quickly even if
the engineer hits the emergency brakes
right away
it could take a train over a mile to
stop over a mile
by that time it's too late the result is
a potentially deadly crash
the point is you can't know how quickly
the train will arrive
the train can't stop quickly even if it
sees you it ends in disaster
if the signals are on train is on its
way
and you just need to remember one thing
stop
trains can't has anyone
said something where you go now that is
an
honor now i believe that as someone that
you really regard
that you trust that came up to you that
said matthew
and smacked you across the face and said
you were brilliant in that
you really were [ __ ] good and you
believed it
um the new york no times
the new york times um now those you know
my best met nick who you know
right who uh is
it works in recruitment he's not in the
industry whatsoever and
we have a relationship where
we are brutally honest with each other
um
we never very very very rarely
complement
each other it would be weird to be too
nice to each other
um and he knows that i have complexes
about various different things
um with regard to my to my acting
um and and yet despite him knowing these
things
he will still say that was [ __ ] which is
why i respect him more than
like so many other people who could tell
me something every single
[ __ ] he says no no but he will tell me
if something is [ __ ] and i'm like well
he knows that
that would genuinely like [ __ ] me up so
if he's saying it then i could take it
as
like that's legitimate but on the flip
side if you think something's good
he will he will when he tells me it's
good i'm like [ __ ]
wow i mean what does nick know he's a
philistine there's nothing about art
but if he's enjoyed it then then
you know maybe what did he like he was
all right what did he like did he like
when you played amelia clark's boyfriend
uh i don't think he saw it um i think
what did he what did he see recently
baby done
uh no he liked happy he enjoyed happy
valley he liked happy valley
i think that was it and how'd that make
you feel when he said it really made you
feel good
yeah it was pretty cool i wasn't that
was nice of him to say
um that was a nice thing again like he's
not you know he's not
he's not the hollywood foreign press
will you believe them
because i'll tell you what a lot of the
[ __ ] that they put out there is [ __ ]
i don't believe anyone and the point is
i don't believe anyone i can't take
compliments all right that's i've got a
problem i've got a complex i don't know
well when your wife looks in the eyes
and says you're very handsome do you
believe it
no she has to say that what what
happened as a child because i know you
had good parents right
yeah but what is where does the complex
i like to dig deep where does the
complex come from you think
for me i could tell you exactly what it
was my dad told me i wasn't smart
i didn't do good in school i i my mom
told me right in front of me that my
dad's favorite was my brother eric
there are things that i will always
remember that make me go this is why i
am that way and why i have anxiety why i
feel dumb
and that's why i work on them and
realize no they were just
shitty parents at that point to do those
things and i'm not those things i
wouldn't be here if i was that dumb i
wouldn't be here if i was that
so what happened as a kid or something
that made you feel this uh
i don't know less about yourself i think
it's more of a defense mechanism
to be totally honest with you i think if
i was i mean again what how the [ __ ] do
i know
um but i think it's more of a um
it is a way for me i think that the idea
is that throughout my life
uh things have sort of got um
like balls of have got rolling and then
i've gone oh god this is worrying now
because if
if this does quite well suddenly you're
up on that pedestal to be shot down
right
um i had it with this podcast so i'm
doing this legionated podcast and
i was quite nervous about doing a
podcast to begin with
you know yeah yeah so originally it
started off that me and
a couple of friends we got together and
said let's make a podcast about leeds
just us
and we got a guy an ex-player called
jimin beckford to come and do it and it
was
it was going quite well for a few weeks
um and i was really nervous about it
because i was like
once you put that out there you're you
know you're putting yourself out there
and saying here i have an opinion on
this
uh come and take a shot at me and i've
always quite enjoyed sort of just
keeping my head down with regard to that
stuff because if you don't you know
if you don't put your head above the
parapet no one can blow it off um
and so i've not really done it very
often
and it ended up doing really well
long story short leeds united the actual
club got in touch and said would we like
to do
the official one so we've sort of we've
merged our podcast into we are now the
official legionnaire podcast
right [ __ ] now this is a premier league
club a global a global franchise that
people are going to be listening to
and i like that's when i get my anxiety
where i'm like [ __ ] like
now i'm in a position where um
people you know can can can criticize
they're actually going to be listening
to me they'll be paying attention to me
and and i was very close to sort of
pulling the plug so i was like i don't
know if i want that kind of attention
i don't know if i want to put myself in
that in that spotlight to be taking
shots um and i did i went on with it
because because i
i've i developed a few years ago like an
attitude that
that if it scares you you should do it
anyway but my instinct is always to just
go and
i'm i'm all right i don't need to do
that and it's kind of like that i
i hate rejection
and i hate like bad press or bad reviews
so much that i'm like you can't get
badly reviewed if you don't do a play
it's like it's it's it's like this
defense mechanism so the reason i don't
i think that i don't
um believe [ __ ] is because it's like but
if i do believe it say if i go and read
99 reviews of a film okay and they're
all great and i believe all of them i go
brilliant
i know eventually i'm gonna read one
that thought i was terrible and that's
gonna [ __ ] undo everything and make
me feel
ten times worse and so i just think well
i just if i just don't
don't believe any of it i'd have to
worry about it but man i can ignore the
bad ones as well if you take a test you
get a 99 it's an
a if you get a 90 it's an a even if you
get an a
it's a b i know it's for me i know it's
fine i got
50 60 ones i passed 61
of 61 of people like you you still pass
rotten tomatoes is the biggest hunk of
[ __ ] i've ever looked at
i don't know how they do it i know it's
all these people probably that get paid
off
but they say some things are such [ __ ]
that are so great they say things that
are brilliant or [ __ ]
they give things 100 that are like a 70
at best
i mean this is just [ __ ] you
uh i just think that if i if like i said
if i ignore
the good ones then that gives me an
excuse to ignore the bad ones as well
and then i can just have a nice
benchmark of of of average but the
guardian praised your performance and
baby done
i mean what do you want the new york
times the
i mean people loved you and harry potter
you have to know
one thing you don't suck well i've i i
have
i have come to the conclusion again in
recent years
that i can do the job i have i have i
have made that piece with myself i'm
like
you might not be the best actor in the
world um you might not have
you know spectacular range but you can
do a job like you are a safe pair of
hands
and people will keep giving you work and
that was quite even that was like quite
a nice feeling just to get to that point
where i'm like huh
i can i actually can do this like i've
there was there was years where i didn't
even feel comfortable calling myself an
actor like i got paid for it but
i don't know like was i just was just
getting work off the back of harry
potter or whatever
so now i definitely feel much more
comfortable that i can
i can do a job you know yeah
well i think you're far better than
average or uh
what did you call it something hands a
safe pair of hands safe
pair of hands have you ever heard that
ryan is that an english thing
i guess it must be if you've not heard
of it it's just like you know when you
when
when you've got a job for someone and
it's like you don't need someone to
excel you just need a safe pair of hands
that's going to get the job done
hey you know uh we haven't even really
talked about harry potter which is which
is kind of great for you
uh yeah
if somebody's i know you love it i'm
just giving you [ __ ] i know you you
if somebody said if they called you
again they wanted to do
they want to do another harry potter
she's written another book my wife asked
me that
a week ago what would you do she asked
me because there were there was that
that news thing that she showed me about
how they're talking about apparently
they're working on
they're working on some tv series it's
probably [ __ ] i'm pretty sure it's
[ __ ]
or at least like or at least like all it
is is like some guy in an office went
hey we should make a harry potter show
and
yeah we should do that and that's
literally the limit of the story
um but anyway it's big news it's global
it's everywhere it's viral
um because it's harry potter um and my
wife was like would you do it if if they
asked you and i was i
i don't know um i can't confess to have
given it some see
any serious thought but um i don't know
i uh
i don't have a desire to do it let's put
let's put it that way
um like there's obviously many many
factors when it comes to
to whether you're gonna take a job on or
not i mean let's be honest
we're we can claim to be
artists all day long but we're just
professionals and if you know if the
money's right then
you'll probably do a lot of things um
it's such a huge epic thing
in in terms of wanting to go back to
that character
i would genuinely have to say it would
have i mean this is me purely
speculating it's not going to be about
that i'm not going to ask me or anything
like that
but if they did hypothetically i would
have to read
i would have to read everything i'd have
to know exactly what it was who was
doing it
you know i'd always said to my wife
remember when they did like save by the
bell the new class
and it was just mr belding it's like i
don't want to be mr belding
i mean well hang on here's what's great
if they did it think about this
they'd probably put a little suit on you
so you'd look a little heavier
you'd probably they could mess your
teeth up you could look a little bit
different
you can gain some weight for the roll
and you could look not like you again
so you go back to something that you
transfer form
transformation i just
i just don't know if i tell you one
thing about talking about the
my absolute favorite thing about being
an actor right
is the fact that and i don't know if you
have a similar kind of thing
but the the thing with me is that i've
never really excelled at
anything like sport or um
academia like i was i've basically been
fine at everything like i'm not really
bad at anything
um i'm just fine loads of stuff i can do
loads of stuff too hard on yourself um
and so the thing with acting is that
i've never actually had to choose
sit and and and choose a profession
because with acting i can
i can do all kinds of different mad [ __ ]
like i can play soldiers i can play
police officers i can play wizards i can
you know
whatever the role takes i get to adopt a
whole new
lifestyle and a new uh i get to play
dress-up you know i get to get
in costume and play make-believe and
then when i've done with that
i get to move on and do a different one
i've got a really short attention span
and and i get bored really easily with
stuff and
uh and i'm i'm really good at uh
focusing all my energy into something
for a really short space of time like
i will i will get when i'm on when i'm
on something that i that i'm enjoying
i'll be like
i'll be obsessed with it i'll be
obsessive i'll wake up in the morning
i'll be up i'll be like
first thing i think about i want to do
it do it do it and after about a week
i go yeah i'm bored now and i'll move on
which with the
with with with acting is so great for me
because i can be
fully invested in a role for a couple of
months and then i go yeah i'm done with
that now i get to go and do a different
one
and it just keeps it fresh all the time
and exciting and
and uh i guess off the back of being in
harry potter for 10 years
i really enjoy the freedom of being able
to do that
and um and i have kind of shied away
from a lot of
um roles and and stuff that have that
have been
oh this could potentially be another
seven years and i'm just even without
like i'll do the self tape or whatever
but
i can feel it when i'm doing the tape
like my heart's not in it
because it's like i i don't know if i
want to do something for 10 years
yeah i do the same thing it's it's a lot
of
it's a commitment it's like you know you
be careful what you wish for because
you know i'm extremely grateful and i
always have to preface it with that but
when i did seven years ten months a year
i'm on that show and i didn't see my
family much and i
uh that's that's what you're doing
that's the role you are that's you know
that's it
so uh you know you gotta weigh the
options go wow success
fame money all this no life
or it depends if you're struggling too
it also depends
if you're struggling i would work at
mcdonald's so if we're both working at
mcdonald's i would do whatever the
i worked at mcdonald's once that's what
i mean like i think it's it it's it's
it's a very it's very often that people
go like you talk about the industry and
and there's like if people take a money
job or whatever there's an idea of it
it's selling out or
or you you're not a resp you you not
respecting the art form or
you whatever it's like the end of the
day it's a [ __ ] job all right
we're all trying to earn a living okay
we're not we didn't all make 25 million
dollars on our last movie
so we're all trying to get to the next
job and make our next paycheck or
whatever
it's like if i've taken a job because
because it's money it doesn't mean that
i'm selling out it doesn't mean that i'm
like
i'm i'm not going to do a good job i'm
still going to give 110
i'm going gonna earn that check it just
means that
maybe it's a piece of [ __ ] do you ever
how often do you audition for her uh
american characters where you have to
get rid of your english accent
how many quite a bit quite often
actually is it hard for you
most no no so i i i much prefer doing
um accents in fact the last
apart from as well so the last film i
did baby done
was my own accent um and i really
struggled with it
i hate doing stuff with my own accent um
because
i just i just find an accent
is so some people find it a bit of a
straight jacket and they find it quite
difficult
i go the other way in the i can fully
immerse myself in a character
when they when i when i find their their
voice when i find their accent i can
just
that allows me to just slip into it
so easily um and then suddenly i i have
a loss of inhibitions it's almost
the complete opposite these straight
jackets come off for me i find my own
voice
a straight jacket in that when i'm using
it i
i struggle to differentiate between
myself and the character
and and i get i i have mixed
mixed thought processes that go on in my
head um
and and that just gets confused and i
and i struggle to commit
sometimes to to an action or to a to a
line or whatever
because i don't know who's saying it wow
so your own voice bothers your own
accent
your own accent you're doing that you'd
rather prefer not doing
that's rare usually people want to it's
easier to be
you know talk like this and have a
conversation so you prefer what what is
your favorite uh accent to do
um it's probably i
i really enjoyed doing so i did a show
called ripper street where i played a
cockney
east end of london and uh
that was quite fun because i was living
in london at the time and
you know you get you get cabbies and and
you
you go around to get on the bus or
whatever and you can hear people talking
and it's
it's weirdly it's always an accident
that i'd sort of done like
um just pissing about like at home and
stuff would i
just i'd do it all the time so that was
quite i quite enjoyed doing that and
that was one that i really
as soon as i did that i just
i felt i felt me matthew lewis sort of
just slip away
instantly um let me hear a little
cockney no
no you can't go in we'll just go and
pitch it teach me teach me a word how
would i say
hey great to see you matthew great see
great to see him out here hey uh it's
great great great to see you matthew
matt
they do f a lot of f's see i was right i
said matthew it's great to see you
matthew matthew
yeah why like that uh i heard it like
that
you know i always notice like there's an
actress on a show right now i'm not
gonna say anything but it just
irks the [ __ ] out of me she does this
southern accent
and she's english english she's english
english
and it's i it brings look who destroys
me when i watch she's like well i don't
even care where you're from and i'm like
stop
nobody i mean it's just like it's so
extreme i mean
she could have done a subtle kind of
southern accent but it's like you know
i don't care where you're from you know
who's the accent i absolutely adore and
i can't do it
for the life of me my wife can do it so
well um
is the girl from i should know her name
because she's fantastic
um from ozark he plays ruth oh she's
seen really yeah i've only seen the
first season but she's brilliant oh my
like she's so great in the show anyway
she's fantastic but then her her accent
is just
i've yeah but she feels that she fits
like you believe that she's down there
like
she oh yeah i just buy it but this one
this other one was just came in i just
it was weird when i was listening to it
but what's tricky as well with accents
is that is that i think a lot of people
um think that it's just as simple as
vowel sounds and
and away you go and um and the reason
why i
why i think that that it helped accents
help me get into character more
is his accent is so much more to do with
rhythm than it is to do with actual
sounds
um in my opinion and i think that once
you get the rhythm
of an accent i don't know it just it
it's it's the way someone talks you can
just
there's just things like like so i just
did all creatures great and small and i
was playing
playing a really posh guy i had loads of
money um he sort of spoke very queen's
english
um you know i guess even more posh than
james bond but
it's kind of like the crown like very
appetite very yeah yeah
exactly and the rhythm of him just
it it spoke to me so much about how he
behaved
and and that there was certain dialogue
actually that i read and i was like
that doesn't that's this he wouldn't say
that it doesn't it it sounds ugly in in
the
in the accent i'm doing for him and you
just sort of tweak it a little bit and
i don't know how to describe it just
when you get it right it clicks and it's
really and i think that
it's quite understated finding a
character's voice i think for me
personally
it's it's it's huge for me
inside of you is brought to you by
better help
guys i've talked about this a million
times this is a big part of what the
podcast is about
if uh you're even thinking about therapy
talking to someone better help is who
you need to be talking to
better help is simple affordable um
and available easily available if you
don't want to be seen on video
you could uh just do audio with your
therapist
or you could talk to them via uh phone
computer whatever it is a lot of people
feel that they don't need to talk to
someone and they bottle everything up i
know i did for years i know some people
in my family do the same but when you
talk about it with someone when you talk
about your
your issues and we all have our issues
it just makes life a whole lot easier
and uh
you know what is therapy exactly well
therapy is
whatever you want it to be you get some
tools to help you with motivation
depression anxiety battling your temper
stress dealing with insecurity in
relationships or at work whatever you
need
better help it's time you stop being
ashamed of normal human struggles and
start feeling better because you deserve
to be happy
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video
phone and even live chat sessions with
your therapist
and you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to it's much
more affordable i should know that
living in hollywood california where
therapy sessions could be hundreds and
hundreds of dollars
not with better help uh it's much more
affordable and you can start talking to
your therapist in
48 hours join the millions of people who
are seeking what therapy
is really about it may or may not be for
you but it's worth looking into because
you are your greatest asset this podcast
is sponsored by a better help and inside
of you listeners get 10
off their first month at
slash betterhelp.com that's
betterhelp.com
inside inside of you is brought to you
by butcherbox i've never been more
excited than getting a box of meat folks
i love
meat you know most of us are preparing a
meal a lot of times it involves meat
for those of you who are don't like me
well you shouldn't be listening i guess
because
i love to eat meat butcher box sent me
this box of steaks
and chicken and short ribs and
bacon and just deliciousness it's great
when you have that in the freezer
because you can always prepare a meal
pretty quickly with butcher box i know
you're throwing out a lot of stuff
spring cleaning is here but uh what you
do need to do is get a nice big
box of butcher box that's for damn sure
i love this stuff
you know what i love about butcher box
ryan is that you can get a box of meat
so much cheaper than the grocery store
so you're getting organic good stuff
and you don't have to go to the grocery
store it comes to you
and it's more affordable than going to
the grocery store and getting your meats
don't you like a big hearty steak i
would love a big heartache i'm gonna
make you some short ribs
oh yeah look i love free stuff but when
when it comes to big steaks and short
ribs and meats in a big box
you know doesn't get much better all
meat is free of antibiotics and added
hormones each box has about 10
pounds of meat enough for 24 individual
meals packed fresh
shipped frozen vacuum sealed so it stays
that way
i can customize my box or go with one of
theirs either way i get exactly
what i want it's the best meat shipped
right to my door
which means one less trip to the grocers
options like a hundred percent
grass-fed and finished beef free-range
organic chicken
heritage pork wild-caught alaskan salmon
and sugar nitrate-free bacon
it's the way meat should be right now
butcher boxes offering new members
ground beef for life
that's two pounds of ground beef in
every box for the life of their
subscription
you just go to butcherbox.com
inside it's that easy butcherbox.com
slash
inside get yourself some goods
delicious meats fresh organic
sent to your house who's the best actor
that you loved working with the most
that's a terrible question
the actor you loved working with the
most in the history of your
life so far tara another terrible
framing of a question
um i've i've
thought i mean yeah i mean obviously
like it feels ridiculous to sort of say
anyone else really
um you know there's people who i feel
that i've
i've had closer relationships with and
people who
have probably probably taught me more
um but it just the level of
of just how good he was and
how fortunate and ridiculous it was for
me to have been working with him at that
age
um it seems a bit stupid to even
suggest anyone else i mean he was it's
just
i i watch his performances now and i'm
just like still going just
[ __ ] like i wish i could have that time
again
i wish i could go back and and and do
and
and work with him again and and from
from like what i know now from
everything that i've
appreciate of him now but i've been as a
stupid kid you know kids are stupid
well you were 17 at the end when you had
scenes with him right
now i would have been 20 20 years old
you were 20 years old so you were an
adult
yeah yeah i just um i was i was very
uh i wasn't the outgoing charming man
that you speak to
now i was very very shy back then and um
i didn't uh i didn't
i guess take advantage of the wrong word
but i just didn't uh
i didn't speak too hardly any of them to
be honest with you
um we you know it i just
was terrified of of them for no reason
whatsoever because they're all so
all of them were so nice and so friendly
and you know
the people i've spoken to years later
like
michael gambon and robbie coltrane and a
few of the guys that i've sort of
since become friends with years later i
wish i could have had that relationship
when i was younger i just didn't and
obviously sadly allen's one that
i never got a chance to meet again after
we after the final premieres and stuff
and i just wish that
i wish i mean i guess we all have these
regrets of when we're younger we look
back and we go oh [ __ ] you idiot why did
you do that or why didn't you do that um
but i do i would that's why i do wish i
could go back and and work with him
again knowing what i know now yeah
that's pretty profound and it is it's
sad it's like you know
but that's like you take it as this was
a great moment i got to watch him work i
got to work with him
and you take take it for you know take
it for what it's worth and what you did
even like telling them
like i guess they must hear it all the
time like people like that must
must genuinely hear it all the time oh
my god i'm your biggest fan oh i think
you're amazing
but you know as a young actor like these
are people who
have shaped you in ways you didn't even
realize just from a film you watched
when you were nine like you know what i
mean like they
they have they have had an impact on
your career without you even realizing
it some of them
and i don't feel i mean i said i did i
did tell alan
that actually on on the last day i did
say something
along those lines um so many of them i
i didn't well i i i i think i
must have told you this i um on on his
last day i went to his trailer and
even knocking on his door [ __ ]
terrifying um
and uh and i just said to him
hey um i know it's your last day and i
just want to say
this has been incredible like to have
worked with you for
this long i know that i have not really
spoken very much
um but i just wanted to say that it
wasn't
you know it was because i was terrified
but you were incredible and
i just want to say thank you for
allowing me to work with you for
10 years and not ever shouting at me or
you know treating any of us anything
less than you're equal
um and he was like come on in and
when he put the kettle on and we had a
cup of tea and we just chatted about
what i was going to do you know in my
career going forward and
what he recommended i do and and uh
yeah i mean it was just i'm so glad i
did that i wish i'd done it
five years earlier you know i mean um
but i was
at least i can say i did that like
that's one thing like i never did that
with anyone else
i didn't know that story oh yeah yeah so
because he was i think he was um
i don't know what his job title was but
he was he was he was a
quite important radha at the time i'm
not entirely sure exactly what he was
like he was
president or something of rad or i don't
know um and he was talking about how he
thought i should go to drama school
um that was probably him
very politely criticizing me um i'm
kidding i'm kidding but this is what
goes through my head all the time right
um but he was no he did say you can do
it he said that to me those are these
words
you know you you can do it um
but his point was that i would need um
my skills would need honing and he was
absolutely right about that and he
recommended theater and doing theater
and that's why i did
some theater which i mean he couldn't
have been more right about that that
i learned so much more so much more
about myself
as not only just an actor but as a
person
like what what do i want out of life
what do i want out of this career i
learned all that on stage i didn't learn
that on harry potter
i learned all that like when you're in
the firing line of
of critics every week on stage um
and uh i developed all my
thick skin and and and well thicker skin
um doing that and that's what i think he
was
telling me to go and do you know going
because how if you're doing harry potter
you've got it easy
you're uh you can hide behind a lot of
people you can hide behind scenery for
crying out loud you can get away with
a lot when you're doing 40 takes of
every scene
and and you've got
spells going off and explosions and all
this it's they can just chop and chop
that to pieces they're going to make
everyone look
respectable you know so were there yeah
um yeah were there times
where can you go ahead sorry finish that
no i was just gonna say when you're on
stage you don't have that luxury
did you see a lot of people like some
people who just couldn't get their lines
out and then you watched their
performance you're like holy [ __ ]
they cut them perfectly yeah of course i
mean i i still see that i still see that
on on tv shows that i've done i can't
get the lines out i can't get the
[ __ ] what is it what is it yeah yeah i
mean that's
i think that's one of the important
things as well about about and not just
hollywood
but just just the industry in general is
that
what people have to believe at home is
that it's all it's all make-believe it's
all
um curated you know
um to make the person look as
as good as they possibly can do um
and that's not me being critical of
performances of people at all i'm just
saying
that people have to be realistic about
these things um
whereas in theater again you don't have
that luxury it is
you're on your own you're yeah you're
out there you're on your own
and you are bearing your soul
in a way like you're saying to all these
people in the theater here guys
this is an expression that i feel and i
hope you like it
and they might like it they might hate
it and that's quite a terrifying thing
to do
really um i i
i guess it's like writing a song you
know you write a song and you play it
um it might be the [ __ ] worst song of
all time or it might be brilliant you
don't know until you play it in front of
people but
what it's come from here right and
that's a very bearing
naked vulnerable thing to do um
and uh that's where i guess that's where
the thrill comes from isn't it i guess
we all must be adrenaline junkies in
some way
oh yeah it's funny because i get this
adrenaline you get you get a job and
then you go oh my god then you go into
the fear stage
and then you start walking now yeah you
start working it out you're like okay
maybe i can do this then you get to set
there's just
all these emotions you go through it's
kind of crazy all right this is called
[ __ ] talking with matthew lewis this is
uh rapid fire
uh little lisa can you share with us one
of your favorite behind-the-scenes
moments that happened on the set of
harry potter
one that maybe you haven't told uh that
is they've got to be supposed to be a
quick fire isn't it
you know i hate these questions i hate
these questions because you know i'll
tell you why
just quickly while i think of it in the
back of my mind i hate these questions
right because
we've been answering questions like this
for like more than 10 years now
and i always feel it's it's it's not
fair to say the same old [ __ ] so i try
and think of something new
and and i can never think of anything
and
so i get really stressed because i want
to get i want to give something that's
new and exciting
you could just come up with something it
could be the same thing you've said
before but just real quickly
a behind-the-scenes moment what's the
one one thing that you remember
um okay so i remember one time um
speaking of accents
i remember one time on harry potter
one philosopher i had to say a line
has anyone seen my toad as in like
trevor
the toad like a frog thing and um
because of the way i actually speak my
accent is has anyone seen my toad
and chris columbus was was sort of in a
sterics behind the monitor
and and i did it a few more times anyone
seen my toad
and eventually he had to come out and he
says matthew it
it sounds like you're saying has anyone
seen my turd and it sounds like you've
hidden
a little [ __ ] around the common room and
people
american audiences are not gonna
understand what you're saying
so i had to work with sandra freeze who
was like our voice coach
to figure out a way that i can say has
anyone seen my toad
instead of turd and i haven't seen the
film in like [ __ ] 20 years i don't
even know if it i think they probably
cut it out i don't know
i think it was it sounded so much like i
would say there's anyone seen my [ __ ]
the uh they claim that that's a great
story if you could uh leanne if you
could only put one thing on your bucket
list what would it be and why
um i want to go so i've done so i had a
few things on my bucket list and i've
managed to
inexplicably take off quite a few
already so i wanted to go i had three i
had
a bucket list of three which is me just
bragging about cool [ __ ] i've done but i
was gonna do
great white shark diving uh a bungee
jump and a skydive and i've done all
three
so i've been thinking lately like now
that we're all in lockdown like what the
[ __ ] am i going to do when we come out
of lockdown
and one thing i want to do which i don't
know is going to speak very much to the
american audience
but i want to go and watch an ashes
series which is cricket
down under in australia so it's england
v australia they play every two years
they've been doing it for 140 years or
whatever and i want to go and
watch one in australia they alternate
home and away and the next one is
the end of this year in australia and i
really want to go [ __ ] that sounds cool
uh claudine anne i know you're a huge
leeds united fan how do you feel the
premier league is doing during the
pandemic
um it's been the mental season it's been
created the craziest season i've ever
seen um
i think that everyone is is i guess
suffering is is kind of the word teams
are suffering from the pandemic
obviously
no one's got any money so no one's
signing loads of players um
it feels like we've had a very short
preseason so maybe some teams aren't
quite as up to speed as they were
um i think it's just been very
unsettling for a lot of teams you know
all like trying to be in bubbles
and it's meant there's been some
completely insane crazy results
which the only people who actually the
people who benefit is the spectator
it's been the best season of football
i've seen in
years and that's not just because leads
are in it i mean we are like the most
entertaining team
in world football right now but that's
not the point is that it's just
the panda the the pandemic has been
terrible for for many many reasons
but it has made football more
interesting
so every cloud right yeah maisha is
there a dream role you wish you could
play in any genre
uh i um
would like to do a western i would like
to play a cowboy i i i'm quite
fascinated by
i do love that era um
like i just like the costumes and and
like do you know maverick like not the
original but the film with mel gibson i
always thought he looked so [ __ ] good
in that and i always wanted to dress
like maverick and then
i was watching um butch cassie the
sundance kid again over christmas
and i was thinking just how amazing
robert redford looks in that movie like
how cool is sundance and they're
incredibly handsome too
just like what a character so i'd love
to play someone like that sundance kid i
could never do it but uh that
would be a dream yeah i'd probably be
the guy that has like a really shaggy
beard and he's like the third horse
behind
is like owen take care of it and i'm
like
you got it boss i'd be that guy yeah
i'll
i'd be that loser guy in the you know
when they're trying to blow uh when
they're trying to blow up the um they're
trying to rob the train right
and there's that little guy who's locked
himself inside and he's like i work for
eh
i'd be that guy that'd be me i would
take both those roles for us did you
work in the west yeah yeah right let's
do it uh last one
taylor k what was your favorite harry
potter film i know you've been asked it
and did you keep any props from any of
the movies anything
um my favorite one to watch does
that mean to watch i guess how about to
watch or to
or you or just your most the most
entertaining one man i've
i've only seen them all once um i i i
i think i i it's the most recent one so
it's a bit of a cop-out but i think the
last one was
was pretty exciting wasn't it i enjoyed
watching that i remember getting
there's something there's something
quite exciting about it being
being the end i mean it was quite uh
there was a thrill involved that you
know when the final battle was was
about to start you know we're going into
act three and it was like oh [ __ ] like
this is
this is it now it's all gonna kick off
and um
there was something quite exciting about
that i i did enjoy that film a lot and
it was pretty like
action-packed fast-paced didn't let up
very much
i was in it a lot the hellos that was
good yeah deathly hallows part two
i think that one i don't remember the
rest of them to be honest i like the
fourth one goblet of fire was good
i remember goblet of fire being quite
good because i like the whole tournament
that's why
tr try try wizard tournament
yeah that's right so i was a tournament
i enjoyed all that stuff
that was good um what's the next
question
did you take any props home anything oh
yeah yeah i took loads of stuff actually
we weren't allowed to take very much um
and we weren't allowed to take anything
um managed to
smuggle stuff out so we couldn't get
ones ones were
no um but i tell you what i've got which
is gross i've got my false teeth which
is disgusting i'm just gonna ask you
that
you have your false teeth yeah yeah i
kept them and
i kept uh like the the fake ears
that you know when they you know when
they the pixies pulled my ears yeah i
kept them i've got those latex like ears
uh wow what else i got i've got um well
speaking of try was a tournament i took
a chunk this is such a weird thing to
take
but the maze where they did the the one
of the things was in a maze
and i just took a chunk of the maze like
of the tree i just took a chunk of that
um i've got my entire costume from the
final
movie that's great i would say you did
it because that they might be able to
figure it out
but someone came into my dressing room
at the end of the day
on the last day and was like do you want
this and i said yes i said put it in
your bag right now
and i will leave the room and i said
okay so
i i uh i i guess i stole that
um so i've got i've got that um which is
cool
because when you go to the museum and
they have the one there
and they say oh that's the one that you
wore in the film i'm like no it's not
because i've got it um but there was
like
we had like multiple costumes for
different units and stuff but the actual
hero one the main one
i've i've got that do you ever think
you'd ever put it up in the house as a
prop
i was like you know like look at me
you'd have to get one of those uh
what do they call them do you know
partitions glass or whatever the
no like a mannequin had to get a
mannequin to to to dress up with it a
bit weird wouldn't it
i was thinking so this is this is gonna
this is we just moved into this house
well we moved in last year but we've not
had any
money to do anything um so we've we've
this is very bad this this is my office
slash guest room
um and i've just started to put stuff on
the walls and if you can see behind me
i've got like a
i've got a electric screwdriver over
there okay i can
could do diy stuff i can do that i can
do manly things
nice and so we're um i'm putting shelves
up
and i'm gonna be putting stuff up and
i've actually just asked
if there's any way to get like a harry
potter poster or something that i can
put up on the wall
just because i've never i've never
really been a collector of my own stuff
i've always found it a bit embarrassing
a bit a bit cringe-worthy a bit
um i don't know i'm always so desperate
to not be
self-promotional and not be um
like self-aggrandizing i guess i don't
know i just i don't like to show off
very much
so i never bothered to get anything like
any like magazine covers that i've been
on or
or film posters i don't own any of this
stuff
and i just suddenly thought like i'm
maybe again i'm getting older or
whatever i thought it'd be quite a nice
thing to put up actually
so i've uh i have i know you are do you
know you know what it's funny because
the reason i said i said to my mate i
was like you know what every time i go
around an actor's house they've got all
these
amazing posters and photographs of them
with like people i remember that one of
you and clint eastwood and i'm like why
the [ __ ] do i have
anything yeah well by the way it's okay
like my thing is
it goes in your office or maybe your
podcast room
nothing else like for me the rest of the
house you don't touch
but if you want to keep pictures of you
and actors and things and stuff it can
go in your office that's you
so have a harry potter poster put up
your uh
suit i mean i feel like i looked at the
picture of you and clinton eastwood
while i was having a piss
was in the bathroom down oh that was in
the bathroom screening room but i took
that down and i put i put a uh
taxidermied uh piranha fish
okay but no you're right but i should
like i think the idea is that like
there's there's a there's a level of
humility that you can have
but then sometimes you can go you know
what that was [ __ ] cool i'm proud of
that [ __ ] yeah and i haven't quite got
there yet but i would like to be able to
to do that a little bit more i'm just
i'm really i'm really bad at
self-promotion i'm really bad at it i
don't like doing all that well look
i love that you do therapy i love that
you're constantly working on yourself
i think you're terrific i think you're a
great actor i think you've done a lot of
great stuff and it's time to start going
hey
i'm good i'm humble i'm
you know and you know it's it's you you
really are hard on yourself i'm hard on
myself
it's amazing you don't have more anxiety
because i you know
being hard on yourself is is taxing
because you got to love yourself and
believe in yourself and all these things
and that's it it's easier said than done
and i think that takes a lot of work but
i think you know you're on a good path
and you're a lot younger than i am
what are you 31 now yeah 31 yeah jesus
man that means when i was 16 you were
zero
[Laughter]
well look man i just think i i think
it's about i think it's about
context i think it's about
appreciating um that
that our industry is [ __ ] in so many
ways and that you you you get put
scrutinized and put on the spot and it's
you're all based on how you look and
and and and like know what like so few
industries in the world
people can openly slag you off
on social media or whatever and it's
encouraged like people people do that
and it's fine like
and and i think that um you have to look
at it in context and go yeah
but we're also doing what we love not
many people get paid to do it what they
love
and and we we're we're handsomely
you know rewarded for it and it's sort
of you just gotta
take it on the chin and and ultimately
ultimately and here's the key thing i'm
trying very hard to do in recent years
and i said this earlier
and i think everyone in every industry
can benefit from this
but it's like do it for you obviously
you've got to
get money on you know money in the bank
and whatever but do it for you
like when when you go and i say this to
every
every time someone asks me about oh how
do i become a young actor what do i do
what's the best advice
i've got no practical advice for actors
i don't know [ __ ] about it i make it up
as i go along
but what i'll say mentally is that you
just have to appreciate
the the what you are doing
all has to come from here like for it to
be real and believable
and accurate it has to come from here
and just because someone else's ex
lived experience isn't the same as yours
and so they don't get
it it doesn't mean it's not right it
doesn't mean that someone else won't get
it
so when you go into a casting room where
you do a tape you go hey this is my
truth this is what i'm bringing to this
character this is what i think works
if you don't get it it doesn't mean it's
[ __ ] it doesn't mean it's wrong
just wasn't what they were looking for
but yeah someone else might have liked
it i don't think there's such a thing as
a bad actor oh okay there are some bad
actors
i don't think there's bad actors on film
and tv i don't think bad actors get jobs
i think lazy actors might get jobs
and i think that certainly like take
nicolas cage for example right
he does some mad [ __ ] okay completely
mad choices
really wild but it speaks to some people
might not speak to everyone but it
speaks to some people
and that's that's that's art isn't it
and if if
if he enjoys it then
i was just going to end it with you know
what should make us all feel good is
you know there there's always going to
be great actors but there's
always going to be a lot of shitty
actors that are also working
and god bless them that are happy so why
should shitty actors be happy
and someone who's not as shitty
now i'm not saying me i'm saying in
general so it's like look there's
everybody there's actors that are like
they know they're not that great but
they're working they're doing whatever
and they're happy and they're
hey we can't all be de niro we can't all
be whatever
right you gotta do it for you we gotta
do it because we love it we gotta do it
because
also when you know even this podcast
like i was thinking of quitting it a
while back and you know then i realized
wait a minute there's people who
benefit from this and people who really
uh
love it and i go and the big question
was do you love it and i'm like
yeah that's it that kind of that's the
question and that
is fulfilling to do something you love
my brother's like i heard your new song
today
because i just i'm coming out with a new
album and he goes
you know i really love it i go yeah
cause what are you gonna do with it i go
i don't know i'm not gonna ever be a
rock star but i did it because i really
just love music
it's as simple as that and particularly
in a pandemic we're all in lockdown
we're all
[ __ ] trying to figure out what to do
with ourselves if you're doing a podcast
and one person's listening to it
are you enjoying it because that's all
that matters i don't know because
it's just one no i know what you're
saying yeah we probably don't enjoy it
then
you should stop then you should you
should absolutely stop and just
never do a podcast but if you enjoy the
point is if you're enjoying it just
[ __ ] keep doing it who cares man yeah
i enjoy it i enjoy it and i enjoyed this
conversation
that's all right hey uh this was awesome
i i hope to see you man it's been too
long when this is all over uh
hopefully you'll come back i'd love to
come to florida where what
don't say where you are but maybe if
you're close to my grandmother's i could
make a pit stop where's you where's your
grandmother
she lives in uh fort lauderdale of
course she does i knew you should be
live down there what's god's waiting oh
i'm not near there
huh that's god's waiting room yeah i
don't live down there
um but um you're more than welcome
anytime of course come hang out with us
and uh you can stay in in this bed here
i'll keep the bed i'll keep the bed
just until you uh until you've stayed in
there that's a good reason to get rid of
it
after i've but it's going to be full of
posters of just me i love it
give me something to jerk off to at
night yeah
dude i love you man give angela my love
and thanks for coming on and thanks for
allowing me to be inside you again buddy
it was my pleasure
thank you matthew lewis for uh joining
us on the podcast
it was a real pleasure having you on um
i hope you guys enjoyed that and if you
were listening if you're here for
matthew lewis i hope you stick around
for the next episodes we've got great
ones coming up
and um yeah we also had jason isaacs
the week before uh from harry potter as
well so you could listen to him
kind of a back to back harry potter uh
extravaganza
trying to rope in a certain audience
here michael yeah i think we're trying
to
rope in any audience yeah um we have a
great audience and there's a
great listenership here and i love them
dearly and my patrons if you want to
join patron uh
it's a way to support the podcast extra
on the side
and uh without my patrons i don't know
if i'd have a podcast
so thank you all my to all my patrons
you can go to patreon.com
inside uh don't forget the big uh show
this coming weekend march 27th 2 p.m and
6 p.m
pacific standard time for sun spin we're
going to probably play
the whole set of our album maybe some
covers we might
leave out a few songs that we're not in
love with
you go to sunspin.com for all the
information all merch
and if you want any anxiety podcast uh
merchandise you go to the inside of you
online store and the code is
uh inside ryan 15. inside ryan15 for 15
off everything on the inside of your
store that's pretty good because we just
got brand new tumblers so people are
going to do that they're autographed
no i got a graph we got autograph mugs
all that stuff so check that out and uh
why don't we go to the
patron shout outs these are all the
people who uh
subscribe on the patreon and give a
little extra and uh they deserve a shout
out and i'm happy to read their names
off
nancy d mary b leah s trisha f sarah v
little lisa you kiko jill e brian h
lauren g nico p robin s jerry w robert i
jason w uh apothean
apatheon oh i believe apotheon is a new
one
is that not like a sect of philosophy it
could be
a sect of philosophy yeah sure apotheon
apothean kristen k not to be confused
with kirsten crook
emilia oh allison l just j lucas m
raj c joshua d emily s
cj he samantha let's [ __ ] this up
m that's correct jennifer n jackie p
stacy l carly h gen s jamal f janelle b
carrie b tab with 272 knots can be
confused with tabitha 273
ashley ryan kimberly e mike e marissa
and el don supremo dan
jack s ramirez beth b
santiago am sarah f chad w lee np
rey a maya p maisha give him my issue
whisper
maddie asked kendrick f ashley shannon d
[Music]
she's like why did you just yell my name
with a d matt w
berlinda and belinda not berlinda
belinda kevin v
james r chris h osborne dude
h amc dave h samantha s spider-man
chase sheila ray h
yes alyssa c tabitha
t misha n h
close tom and henry s kdf
you were close kdf liliana a michelle
k hi michelle hannah michelle s
and we'll get into the bottom line here
talia m luke h john s andrew t
claire m liz j laura l chat l rochelle e
nathan e brandel taylor k neil a marion
e
megkay janelle p dan n jennifer j
wayne m diane r ojeda lorraine g
olga c corey m and carrie
h that's a big list it's a lot of people
is it getting bigger
yeah it's it's a fine list and you know
if you don't know about patreon i'm just
gonna give you a little glimpse into it
uh these people all contribute a little
extra on the side they don't have to
um and they get some perks as well but
really they're helping the podcast out
and they
uh the top tiers which you just heard
their names they get merch sent to them
every three months
and a little note from me and
[Music]
they get to ask guest questions um
called [ __ ] talking they um get to ask
me questions on inside of me when you
have
asked me questions once a month um and a
bunch of other stuff i also do inside of
you
uh youtube lives just for patrons where
i play music and rob comes over and we
jam
and people have request lines and i also
do a zoom every once in a while with
everybody
but it's a lot of fun and uh patreon has
become a big family and a lot of people
have become
really close friends on it and that
means a tremendous amount to me
um so there you have that uh i believe
that's all that's everything for today
uh i hope you enjoyed the uh interview
and i hope you come back next week
ryan from the hollywood hills from the
hollywood hills
michael rosenbaum uh my name is michael
this is
ryan and um thank you for allowing to be
inside of each and every one of you
um it's always a pleasure and i hope you
had fun so wave to the camera and
we'll see you next time
[Music]
you know what that was back to life got
it got it